marie françoise pascal sa voix j'ai 69
ans je suis à la retraite depuis le 1er
mars 2011
mais pas en retrait puisque je suis dans
plusieurs associations en tant que
bénévole c'est une grande fierté d'avoir
une épouse tel qu'il est tel qu'elle est
telle qu'elle est parce que ça l'est
toujours partante jeu pendant toute ma
carrière professionnelle j'ai été
assistante sociale et mon dernier post
qui a duré 30 ans était à la sécurité
sociale où j'étais responsable du
service action sanitaire et sociale pour
moi je suis fier de ce qu'a réalisé je
dirais le couple sa voix parce que
pascal a réalisé de très belles choses
parce qu'effectivement elle était
entourée de militants
depuis tout petit je suis tombé je
dirais dans dans les personnes âgées
puisque dans ma famille on vit très
âgées très vieux et j'ai côtoyé et mes
grands parents pendant longtemps
donc moi j'étais dans le bercer par ce
lave pendant toute mon enfance et mon
adolescence donc tout naturellement ça
m'a porté vers commun ce public là les
personnes âgées les personnes
handicapées et je ne me sens pas une
personne extraordinaire mais quelqu'un
qui a envie de faire des choses pour ce
but ce public là
donc voilà